welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Carlos heir the tea lorrison Riggs
professor of history and religious
studies at Yale University he
specializes in the social intellectual
religious and cultural history of late
medieval and early modern Europe with a
strong focus on both the Protestant and
Catholic Reformation the history of
popular piety and the history of death
professor Eyre is the author of a number
of scholarly books including war against
the idols the Reformation of worship
from Erasmus to Calvin from Madrid to
purgatory the art and craft of dying in
16th century Spain and a very brief
history of eternity
he is also ventured into the 20th
century and the Cuban Revolution in his
memoir waiting for snow in Havana which
won the National Book Award in
nonfiction in 20 2003 and has been
translated into more than a dozen
languages but alas is banned in Cuba his
latest memoir learning to die in Miami
published in 2010 explores his boyhood
exile experience today we'll talk with
Professor air about what it's like to
write two very different kinds of
history one kind through research and
the other from memory
welcome professor air thanks for
inviting me to your part of this program
let's start with talking about your
memoirs and give us a little bit of a an
overview of them and then how they fit
together yeah well the first memoir
which I wrote in 2000 covers my
childhood in Cuba from my earliest
memories to the day I leave that's when
the book ends so the I left Cuba April 6
1962 learning died in Miami picks up
immediately that evening when I arrive
in the United States and goes through up
to about 1965 or so
when I reunite with my mother because I
left without my parents so that's the
the book ends of that story is leaving
my parents and then reuniting with my
mother okay
and you do you write very scholarly you
know publications and I'm wondering how
it is different for you writing the
memoirs versus doing your scholarly
research I love both uh-huh but I have
to say that if I were to compare the two
the scholarly research is like climbing
a very steep mountain with a 75 pound
backpack the memoirs are a walk through
the park they require no research I
wrote the first memoir in three months I
wrote the second memoir in two months my
scholarly books take me about an average
of ten years of peace
Wow that is very different yeah it's
very different I can write really fast
because all all the research is strictly
up here I I looked up nothing for either
memoir except for one thing
I looked up one fact just out of
curiosity which was how many men had
landed at the Bay of Pigs invasion okay
for my own curiosity not because it made
any difference to the story okay you
know that is it's I admire people who
can remember their childhood with such
you know detail and accuracy
unfortunately I don't have that talent
so I don't know if I'll ever be able to
what write my own memoir I don't think
it's a talent I think circumstances have
a lot to do with it really in my case
you know I left abruptly I left without
my parents and I have never been back so
all of that is it's kind of like an item
inside a snow globe for me it's
preserved every time I see film or
photos from present-day Cuba I get
thrown for a loop because my memories
are messed with right my memories are
kind of pristine because I've never gone
back
and I think that has a lot to do with it
and how old were you again wear it when
you were airlifted out eleven eleven
that must have been my daughter is 11
that must have been a terrifying moment
for you
it wasn't terrifying it was exhilarating
because I was so desperate to leave the
place was so horrible as a child right
and your parents tell you constantly
everything will be fine we'll be
together again
you know you believe your parents at
that age so yes there was an element of
fear but it wasn't terrifying you know
I'm wondering how you ended up doing the
scholarly work you you you currently do
did it was it born out of your
experience in Cuba
you know what led you to do the work
that you do it's combination of things
for one thing my father was immensely
interested in the past and he collected
antiques so in our household the past
was always more important than the
present I think that had a lot to do
with it but the turning point for me
came very early first inkling that I
wanted to be a historian was when I was
living in a foster home for juvenile
delinquents in Miami and the only place
where I could escape was a public
library I went there every evening and
spent two three hours there and
gravitated to the history section and
pretty soon I had gone through all of
the children's section and and was given
permission to check out some of the
adult history books and that's when I
can identify I got hooked of course at
that point I didn't think I wanted to be
a professor because I didn't even know
what a professor yeah so I can't trace
it exactly to that but that's a moment
where I can I can say with you know with
clarity that's when I got hooked on on
history in the past but you write
predominantly about religious history
correct yes so let's talk a little bit
about you know that the work you're
doing now I'm particularly interested in
the the levitation and the the shift in
- towards miracles right because I work
in the area that's the transition from
medieval to modern right and what what
what distinguishes modern from medieval
what is modern well a modern there's a
mind shift away from the miraculous it
but only at the upper levels of the
intelligentsia when you say modern what
you're where it let's say invention of
the printing press 1450 changes learning
completely
so from 1450 on there are individuals
who begin to back away from medieval
beliefs in miracles and you know
steadily becomes more and more
acceptable among the intelligentsia and
especially among Protestants to say that
miracles have not happened since
biblical times what I study is the messy
part I study the the not only the
continuation of medieval attitudes but
among Catholics the embrace of those
attitudes and the exaggeration of those
attitudes so a subtitle for my project
is a history of the impossible I look at
miracles that you know we in our day and
age deemed totally impossible such as
levitation or by location being in two
places at the same that that these are
miracles that are not healing miracles
over which there are always question
marks was it natural or was it a miracle
but you know if you have accounts and
hundreds of witnesses who say so-and-so
was ten feet off the ground then as a
historian you've got a problem with
something like that well I say that you
know we bring really big brackets to put
around the problem where we don't ask
the question did so-and-so really
levitate ten feet off the ground but the
question becomes what
can we make of these testimonies how do
you explain this how do you explain it
it's hard it's very hard you know
occasionally I struggle with this
because at one talk when I was going on
and on at detail in detail about history
of the impossible someone raised their
hand and said excuse me you're not
dealing with history the impossible
you're dealing with the history of the
ridiculous well that's the danger it's
very thin ice that you go out on when
you start putting these things strictly
in context and and saying that you can't
really go much deeper than the belief
that people were perhaps convinced they
saw this and you know the question mark
remains over the event but you know as a
cultural historian or as a social
historian one can approach these
miracles and try to figure out what they
tell us about the transition to
modernity and how complex it was and you
know it's not like the belief in these
miracles has gone away it has not is
still part of Western culture it's not
just as big a part but it's still it's
still a live wire for many people so in
a way analyzing this in the 16th or 17th
century there's also a way of shedding
light on something as part of our
culture here and now today so what would
you what were some of the reasons why
there is perhaps a shift away from the
belief in miracles in modern times for
one thing the Protestant Reformation has
a lot to do with it
although the Protestant Reformation is
informed by many trends from the
previous century
but the fact that the Catholic Church
claimed that all of these miracles
happened and the fact that the church
argued that it's the fact that it was
genuine that it was the real thing that
it was the one true church could be
proved through these miracles made
Protestants back away from these right
and and say no this doesn't prove
anything but in fact what this proves is
that you're constantly tricking people
and so it becomes a polemical issue
there's also a in protestant theology
you know what the most rarified upper
levels if you want to deal just with the
theology they have a different take on
how it is that God interacts with the
world so it becomes a theological and
philosophical question for Protestant
theologians you know how do spirit and
matter relate to one another how does
the natural relate to the supernatural
and they go from there and like for
instance in Catholic ritual there is no
ritual more central than a celebration
of the Eucharist the mass in the
Catholic belief in transubstantiation
which is that the bread and wine becomes
something other than bread and wine
right Protestants had enormous
difficulties accepting this for
theological reasons as well as for
polemical reasons and all this hangs
together I have to say people can float
ten feet off the ground when they're
praying there's a whole long list I
could name possibly over a hundred
theological items topics that are
touched on by making simply that claim
so let me ask you this as a matter of
course scholars build on other scholars
work now you have your scholarly work
that you've done and
of course your memoirs is there any
difference for you if someone uses your
scholarly work versus uses your memoirs
as a part of their scholarly work how do
you feel yeah I haven't seen too much of
the latter all right yeah it does happen
once I was visiting University of North
Carolina and someone ran into me and I
was introduced and they said oh I teach
your book I knew immediately which book
it was that they were teaching because
she was from the Spanish Department
right so it's very different I've been
to to literature conferences where I've
been featured and it's very different
it's totally different because I feel
that the writing from memory is is is
simply because it doesn't have all that
work behind it right it's not that I
don't take it seriously but I have a
hard time thinking of it as being the
same as my scholarly but a great huge
enormous difference is that I have
received thousands of emails and letters
thanking me for my memoirs I've only
received three letters in my entire
lifetime thanking me for my scholarship
yes well I'm sure that's understandable
but I mean it's your memoirs are you
know it's so personal to you right so
it's like other you know it's it's
letting other people really have a
microscope into who you are although the
reason I yeah the reason I wrote them
though was not so much to talk about
myself but to write about the history of
the Cuban Revolution in a way that would
be interesting for people that they
could get at it's one thing I know as a
historian is the first-person narrative
gets you to the past more directly than
anything else exactly so that was that
was my sneaky plan when I began to write
the first memoir because I was very
upset and irritated but years and
years and years and years of people not
only asking me what I thought were very
dumb questions about Cuba but actually
very intelligent very well educated
people displaying abysmal ignorance
about Cuba so the professor in me
basically couldn't take any more but the
professors somehow had to strangle
himself and and leave out analysis and
have nothing but narrative and and it
worked I think I think it actually from
the letters and emails I have received
people thanked me not telling my story
they think me for you know enlightening
them about what happened in Cuba or
actually about one third of the letters
I receive are from Cuban exiles because
my book is banned in Cuba so nobody
there reads in Cuban exile who acts very
increasingly say thank you for telling
my story right so I I shuddered when I
thought of the thought of this book
being read by humans because Cubans can
be hyper critical of each other and
hyper critical about the way one deals
with Cuban history so that has been a
very pleasant surprise that actually you
know my story matches up in the minds of
those who have been through the same
experience yeah so will there be a third
no more the first two were unplanned
they just happened their personal
elements things that were going on in my
life that came together that inspired me
I don't have that plus a third one I
don't know what I would write about
because you know it's my life as an
academic which I think most people would
find immensely barring so maybe not
maybe not but I I just I don't see it I
don't see it at this point well thank
you so much for being here with us today
and sharing some of your work thank you
thank you for more information about
Professor air please visit our website
at Yale that edu slash Macmillan report
be sure to join us
for another episode of the Macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale